tie fighters suck there it is that is
the thesis of the video right there in
three little words slap them on a
thumbnail put it in the title and let's
just call it a day friendos you want a
youtube video that gets straight to the
point boom there's your point in fact
i'm gonna take it a step further not
only do thai fighters one of the most
iconic starships to come out of the star
wars canon suck but their basic design
failures are the single biggest reason
the empire lost to a small ragtag bunch
of rebels everything is proceeding as i
have foreseen that's the case there palp
it's too bad you didn't foresee the need
to hire more aeronautics engineers
[Music]
hello internet welcome to film theory
the show that may not have the droids
you're looking for but does have the
content you'll subscribe for so obi-wan
kenobi just finished out its run over on
disney plus and it was a show that
existed some really high highs some
really low lows but despite being a
mixed bag it did exactly what disney
intended got me thinking about star wars
again so good job mouse you won this
round and my first thought was this have
you ever truly stopped to think about
what a bizarre cultural mishmash star
wars actually is i mean you've got
intense akira kurosawa samurai sword
fights
retro flash gordon-esque space adventure
intense allusions to vietnam warfare
intergalactic c-span a heavy dose of
old-timey westerns and heck why not even
throw in some horrible daytime soap
opera romance for good measure i don't
like sand truly a little something for
everybody huh george one of the most
interesting additions though are the
spaceship battles with starfighters that
were clearly inspired by footage of
dogfights from world war ii and uh that
being said am i the only guy who ever
noticed that a lot of the good guy ships
are named after letters in the english
alphabet of x-wing the y-wing the a-wing
i mean it's cool and all but there's
just one teeny tiny problem pretty much
no one in the galaxy uses those letters
not even joking the galaxy's default
writing system in the star wars universe
is aurabesh if you dig deep enough into
the lore you can find that english
letters do exist as something called
high galactic but it's only used by
snobby rich people not exactly the best
look to have your grasses roots
rebellion naming things like elon musk
names his kid looks like the new trilogy
wasn't the only thing making up stuff as
it went along
they fly now
they fly now
anyway today we're not talking about any
of those ships instead we're focused on
the imperial tie fighter backbone of the
empire's navy a ship with an iconic look
and an even more iconic sound
speaking of the shape the tie fighter
supposedly got its name from its twin
ion engines t t-i-e not the fact that
george lucas thought the design looked
like bow ties cause let's face it it's
an easy mistake to make considering that
this is the same guy who named an
overweight x-wing pilot porkins and a
drug dealer sleaze bagano ugh real
creative on the names there george
anyway i don't care how they were named
the thai fighters are garbage and they
cost the empire it's galactic dominance
and let me be clear i'm not talking
about deeply complicated lore stuff here
either these things ignore fundamentals
of dog fighting that are so basic even
the video game star fox got him right
and we all know how accurate star fox
was
tldr emperor shiv needs to have his men
go watch top gun maverick or something
because tom cruise would be so
disappointed in them right now so today
we're going in on a bombing run that's
going to destroy your faith in the tie
fighter in order to show how a few
simple design mistakes can let some nerf
herders overthrow a galactic superpower
let's start off with some backstory
shall we in universe the thai fighters
were the brainchild of imperial governor
grand moff tarkin who demanded the
creation of a new ship that was both
fast and maneuverable while remaining
cheap to produce within just five years
the starfighters used by the fallen
republic were completely phased out in
favor of the ties on a surface level
this makes sense the galaxy was no
longer embroiled in an all-out war with
two sides of roughly equal power instead
the empire was facing smaller weaker
internal rebellions hoping to overwhelm
those insurrections with numbers seemed
like it would be a valid strategy but
once you start to break down how the
ties were designed you start running
into one major problem over and over and
over again sight lines as you can see
ties were designed with a single large
window at the front of the ship well
that creates an immediately recognizable
and iconic design it is horrible for
dogfighting which go figure was the
entire purpose of the dang ship if you
want to see firsthand just how bad the
visibility and the tie would be hop into
a game of star wars squadrons space
combat simulation video game that lets
players take direct control of all the
franchise's starships when you hop into
an x-wing you get an immediate sense of
how much the rebel pilots can see with
their clear canopies cockpits featuring
glass in every direction that you can
turn your head but inside a tie fighter
what do you see sure you have the window
in front of you but everywhere else
metal above you metal behind you metal
either side metal maybe you got a few
slats to peek through it best but that
was it to compare to a modern fighter
jet let's take a look at the united
states's f-35 lightning ii a multi-role
fighter intended to be one of the air
force's primary aircraft during the
prototype phase pilots complained of a
huge blind spot behind the pilot large
enough to be detrimental to their
performance in close quarters
dogfighting as one pilot commented quote
aft visibility will get the pilot gunned
every time the problem came from the
head rest apparently was blocking the
view directly behind the pilot to my
knowledge and research despite sensors
making up for the lack of visibility the
physical issue was never actually
addressed but that physical issue would
be made hundreds of times worse in the
tie fighter because without visibility
it gives up every advantage that comes
from the ship's increased
maneuverability and this isn't just me
making stuff up just look at any space
battle from any installment in star wars
when given a full 360 canopy dome for
their ship people use it they use it to
look around for threats new targets just
check on the other pilots that they're
flying with i mean in this scene alone
from the beginning of a new hope's
trench run my scope's negative i don't
see anything pick up your visuals
counting here
i can't see it we hear that the scanners
aren't picking up fighters so instead
the pilots are told to physically check
the space around them when luke is told
to watch his back he literally turns
around to watch his back meanwhile let's
see how it works with the tie fighters
ramrod straight ahead like they're at
the dmv taking a driver's license photo
because they can't see in any other
direction so you would expect then that
a lot of their deaths would be surprise
attacks from behind and wouldn't you
know it that's exactly what we see rebel
ships pulling up behind them and
knocking the tie fighters out of the air
before anyone checks a scanner and i
should probably call out the continuity
flaw in these things but from the
outside the cockpit window frames are
arranged with the metal lining pointing
directly up and down but from the inside
those windows are rotated slightly so
the metal lining is diagonal to saying
these things suck for lots of reasons
but bad sight lines are only made worse
once you consider the life support
systems that are built into these things
look at what tie fighter pilots in the
movies have to wear masks with breathing
tubes while every other sort of pilot
gets to sit comfortably with only a
helmet advisor that's not an aesthetic
choice the in-universe explanation is
that the imperial era tie fighters
weren't outfitted with basic life
support systems thai pilots had to wear
full uncomfortable spacesuits while
flying their ships in order to avoid
suffocating or freezing to death inside
their own cockpit now if those
spacesuits are anything like the nasa
suits from around the same time as when
the movies came out then they would be
heavy and cumbersome putting thai pilots
at a massive disadvantage as they
attempted to navigate the controls
remember in a dogfight the difference of
a second in reaction times can determine
who lives and who dies but that's not
even what i really care about here top
pilots have been wearing breathing masks
for decades because of g-forces no the
bigger issue here again is sight lines
because they're having to wear this full
protective armor inside the cockpit of a
tie fighter their heads are fully
encased in a helmet with two teeny tiny
small little eye holes suddenly their
visibility goes from this to this add in
the window and it crops it down even
further to this now compare that to the
sight lines of the rebel pilots pilots
flying inside a ship stocked with life
support the visors on their helmets are
wide and completely open giving them
once again full sight lines you'd think
at this point that i'd be done but it
gets even worse as if the window
placement and helmet weren't doing
enough to make the pilots virtually
blind adding insult to injury are the
giant wings on these things which are
blocking even more of your peripheral
vision when looking forward and that's
without me even calling out the obvious
these wings are literally a giant target
what's gonna be easier to hit a thin
relatively horizontal rebel plane or a
giant array of solar panels measuring in
at 6.7 meters by 8.82 meters that is 22
feet by 29 feet for context that is
one-fourth the size of a tennis court i
know that stormtroopers can't aim to
save their lives but geez miss those
wings and it's literally the definition
of missing the broad side of a barn and
you see getting hit really matters with
the tie fighter i mean let's be honest
it's gonna matter to any plane but to
the tie fighter any hit is extremely
detrimental remember what i said about
grand moff tarkin wanted these things to
be cheaply made well as a cost-saving
maneuver he had him built without
shields yep you heard that one right no
shield i mean just look at the
millennium falcon our heroes spend the
better part of six movies joking about
how this thing is a piece of junk that's
constantly falling apart and yet even it
had shields because it was flying in
dangerous situations like smuggling and
warfare there we just lost the main rear
deflector shield one more direct hit on
the back water and we're done for but
the most common tie fighters used by the
imperial navy no shields none that's why
we see tie fighters exploding over and
over and over again anytime they're hit
by a single laser blast with that sort
of setup it means that two gunners and
one well-shielded piece of junk can take
out a squadron of tie fighters with ease
easy you call that easy yeah yeah i do
because we see the rebels taken
advantage of this weakness dozens of
times and remember it wasn't like it was
impossible for thais to have shields
vader's personal thai x1 had a shield
but i'm guessing the emperor was too
cheap to pony up for the rank and file
to be protected like his moody
apprentice so the pilots can't see in
order to defend themselves against
attacks and their ships are built like
giant moving targets made worse by the
lack of shields but there's one last
feature that i want to add to this pile
of failed engineering this
that iconic sound that i mentioned
before yep that's going to get someone
killed you see in close proximity dog
fights like the ones that we see in star
wars and the ones that we saw during the
real life world war ii control of the
battle is everything the beginning of an
aerial dogfight is known as the merge
and history has shown time and again
that the pilot who controls the merge
ultimately gets the first shots in and
is therefore exponentially more likely
to win the battle this is most often
accomplished via smart use of radar
reading the position of the enemy and
then getting your ships into the ideal
position to attack before you engage in
battle merge is controlled you win you
know what's really going to ruin your
element of surprise there though
let's just say that thai fighters
weren't going to be super helpful on a
stealth mission of course all of this is
ignoring the fact that in space none of
these ships would be making sound but
i'm playing by the movie's rules so i'm
just gonna go with it if they're indeed
as loud and screeching as we hear in the
movies their arrival on the battlefield
would be noticed long before they were
able to get into attack position thereby
giving up any opportunity to control the
merge and dictate the flow of battle any
way you look at it the imperial tie
fighter was an impossible poorly built
dumb unshielded idiotic low visibility
stupid stupid stupid aircraft ironically
in their desire to create an efficient
mass-producible dogfighter they created
something that was the epitome of
imperial waste a disaster that could
have been averted if they had just
spared a bit more thought and spent a
bit more money per ship in fact here's a
thought experiment during the final
seconds of luke's trench run in a new
hope darth vader flanked by two other
tie fighters lands a shot that takes out
r2d2 he's about to take the killing blow
on luke ship when the millennium falcon
surprises them all from above swooping
in to land a single shot on the left tie
fighter this destroys it immediately
causing darth's other support to get
distracted he loses track of his
proximity to darth and bumps their ships
together sending vader flying out of the
trench all of it gives luke the opening
he needs to land the killing blow
destroying the death star saving the
planet of yavin iv and the rebel base on
there and changing the course of the war
forever now consider if even one of the
changes that we've mentioned to the tie
fighters could have been implemented if
the ties had better visibility above the
pilot like an open glass canopy it's
likely darth vader or one of his flanks
would have been able to see the
millennium falcon coming evade its fire
and stay in formation to kill luke if
the ships had more windows on the side
and less of you obstructing wings the
pilot to darth's right wouldn't have
lost track of his periphery and would
have avoided swerving into darth's ship
and if the basic tie fighters had been
equipped with literally any amount of
shielding that one singular laser strike
from the falcon wouldn't have destroyed
the first fighter only damaging it which
would have given them the extra seconds
they needed to take down luke at that
point the death star would have remained
intact and destroyed yavin 4 killing
princess leia and all the other
rebellion leadership on the planet on
top of that military mastermind grand
moff tarkin would still be alive with
the death star as his flagship
strengthening imperial strategy against
any remaining rebel cells throughout the
galaxy that right there would have
changed the course of star wars history
forever mostly for the worst but hey
lisa would have spared us the horror
that was the rise of skywalker somehow
palpatine returned
instead vampire blew it all because they
wanted to save a couple extra bucks on
their planes but hey if you're like us
and you think way too much about the
military strategy and economics of the
galaxy far far away why don't you check
out our theory talking about how
destroying the death star would have
thrown the galactic economy into turmoil
ruining billions of lives it's an older
theory but it definitely checks out or
if you want something more recent check
out our video talking about the problems
with baby yoda sorry being that cute for
that long would be totally dangerous and
if you want more star wars theories in
the future crash into that subscribe
button like a tie fighter that's been
shot with a single blaster bolt until
then remember it's all just a theory a
film theory and cut